okay so I wasn't planning on talking
about the New Avengers trailer but the
majority of comments on my Project X
review are asking me where my review of
the New Avengers trailer is so here we
go with my review of the Avengers
trailer first time I just want to
quickly say you guys really keep me in
line thank you because I didn't know
about this trailer today so thanks for
telling me about it I went to watch it
and I got to tell you that is one of the
best trailers I have ever seen to
describe the pumped feeling I have about
this movie is impossible I just I cannot
wait to go and sit in that theater and
see what Joss Whedon has in store for me
I purposefully avoid hyping myself for
movies I don't like getting on the hype
train of things because a lot of times
it leads to intense disappointment but I
am all on board the hype train of the
adventures the only word I can think to
describe this trailer is just awesome
there is this this trail is amazing it's
everything that a fanboy would want it
has every little inch of what a fanboy
wants to see in a trailer in a movie
just please don't suck please one of the
things this trailer definitely addresses
is that certain members of the Avengers
are arguing with each other they're not
just though yes happy team wonderful
they don't like each other at first and
that is great because so many of these
characters are so larger than life and
they have egos they're kind of full of
themselves and they're not used to
working with other people so when all of
a sudden they're forced to collide and
join forces it would make sense that
they would have a little bit of a hard
time doing that I like that I actually
got to see some actual line readings
from Mark Ruffalo and while I liked
Edward Norton and I even like eric bana
has an actor very much Edward Norton
with greatest Hulk I really like Mark
Ruffalo as an actor and I'm really
excited to see what he can do with the
character also in this trailer they put
the full circular shot of all of them
and it was like they're like okay look
yes we know that you said that it didn't
look like Hulk was in this shot look
there he is all right now calm down
Hulk is there even though his elbow is
actually in the shot in the first
trailer just letting you know and I am
insanely attracted to Scarlett Johansson
and that's just a huge plus to me I love
redheads it looks like she's acting well
looks intense
looks like I just kind of want to sit
there next to her and talk for a while
and maybe go to dinner but I don't want
to show too much of the trailer in this
review because I want you to be able to
see the trailer for yourself and
experience the awesomeness of some of
the moments in this trailer I'm just
gonna say Hulk Iron Man combination
amazing and Ruffalo has this line in
this trailer that is just great it sums
up the entire feel of the Avengers as a
force as an unstoppable force not just
some team of strong people that have
assembled together but just an
unstoppable force of Awesomeness we're
not a team we're a time bomb
I can't wait to see this film let me
know what you guys think of this new
trailer did you enjoy it as much as I
did are you extremely excited for like I
am can you not wait two more months like
I can't right now just see it you like
my review of the Avengers trailer you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stupid eyes